المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان قوتي بلاده تشن هجمات على ثلاثه محاور
في مقاطعتي دونسك وزابولوجيا موضحا انها
حققت تقدما في بعض المواقع وتصدت لهجمات
روسيه في لمن وكوبيانس
توصل القوات الاوكرانيه عملياتها الهجوميه
في مناطق
وفي منطقه بريوتني حققت قواتنا نجاحات
وذبتت مواقعها بينما تستمر عمليات القصف
المدفعي والصاروخي وتواصل قواتنا هجومها
على شمال وجنوب باخموت وتستمر المعارك في
اتجاهات
دون تغيير في المواقع ويستمر جنودنا في صد
هجوم العدو في اتجاه
المقابل اعلن الجيش الروسي سيطرته على
خمسه مواقع واربعه مراكز مراقبه في اتجاه
فوريتشنز وقال متحدث باسم المنطقه الغربيه
في الجيش الروسي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
فقدت اكثر من كتيبه ومنظومه لاطلاق
الصواريخ من صناعه بولنديه ومنظومه صواريخ
امريكيه واضاف المتحدث ان القوات الروسيه
من اسقاط مروحيه ومسيره في منطقه
في غضون ذلك قال موقع ريدوفكا العسكريه ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل تقدمها في محور
اكرمنايا باتجاه مدينه كوبيانسك على حدود
مقاطعتي لوجانس
وتمكنت من السيطره على مواقع جديده وفي
محوريا قال الموقع ان القوات الاوكرانيه
شنت هجمات على مواقع روسيه قرب افدي افكا
وكريسنو جورلوفكا غربا دوناسك واضاف
الموقع ان القوات الاوكرانيه لم تحقق اي
تقدم جديد بعد هجماتها في اتجاه بلدات
جنوب اريخوف في زابولوجيا
قبل الرئيس الاوكراني
استقاله وزير الزراعه في حكومته وطالب
رئيس الوزراء بالتفكير بالاستقاله كما قال
الرئيس الاوكرانيه السفير الاوكراني لدى
بريطانيا جاءت هذه الاقاله على خلفيه
انتقاد السفير لتصريحات